For this project, I’m going to show you
how to defend yourself on the stick bomb battlefield.
By making a homemade arsenal, of spring loaded
stick bombs and throwing stars, that explode on impact.
Start this project with a handful of popsicle
sticks, or craft sticks like these. I found
mine in packs of 100 at a local dollar store,
and one pack is usually enough to make over
20 exploding stick bombs.
Now let’s get down on the carpet, because
the sponginess of the rug will make it much
easier to mass produce our mini weapons. And
to start, let’s kick off production with
the Boomerang Bomb. It only uses 4 sticks,
and it’s one of the easiest throwing stars to make.
Start by overlapping two sticks on one end
so they form an arrow pointing to the left,
with the yellow stick on the top side. Now
place the red stick on top of these two, so
the bottom lines up with the green stick,
and the top intersects with the middle of
the yellow. To bind them together, hold the
sticks firmly together where the yellow and
red sticks meet the green, then push the tip
of the orange stick under the middle of the
green one, and lock the the other end under
the yellow stick. That’s how quick and easy
it is to make the Boomerang Bomb. And now
if you throw it at a hard surface like a wall
or refrigerator, the sticks will explode on
impact.
Now check this out. With a fairly simple transformation,
and one extra stick, we can easily convert
the Boomerang Bomb into a 5 point throwing
star. Hold the Boomerang with both hands at
the bottom, and carefully push the points
together, in a way that makes the orange and
blue sticks jut out on either side. Now you
should be able to take the red stick and push
one end under the orange piece, then bend
it over and lock it underneath the blue. With
a bit of careful tweaking you’ll have a
great looking 5 point throwing star, that’ll
give a satisfying, spring-loaded burst of
energy when it connects with your target.
Next up is the Butterfly Bomb, and for this
one we need 5 sticks. Start by crossing two
yellow sticks to form an “X”, then drop
a green stick in the center so it crosses
through the middle horizontally. Use your
thumb to hold them down, so you can slide
the end of a red stick under one of the yellow
ones, bending it over the green stick, and
locking it into place under the yellow stick
on the other side. Now use your thumb and
finger to hold this side together so it doesn’t
spring apart, then take the other red stick
and lock it in place on the other side, the
same way you did before. The tension will
hold it together, and that’s how you make
the Butterfly Bomb.
The Hand Grenade, also uses 5 sticks, but
in a completely different way. Place the yellow
stick in the center and overlap the two purple
sticks so they diverge away from each other,
but meet together at the top. Hold all the
sticks together with your thumb, so you can
wedge one of the red sticks so it’s under
the yellow, but on top of the two purple sticks.
Then grab the other red stick and weave it
the opposite way, so it goes under the purple
sticks and over the yellow. This will lock
it together, and the Hand Grenade is done.
These are one of my favorite stick bombs to
make because they hold together really well,
and are one of the most volatile when they
go off.
The Four Square is another quick and easy
build, and uses 6 sticks. Set the two blue
sticks side by side so they’re parallel
to each other, then set two green sticks perpendicular
to the ends so the whole thing makes a square.
The orange stick goes on top so it overlaps
the center of the green ones, and now the
yellow stick needs to slide under the middle
portion of the blue one on the side. Hold
the yellow stick firmly in place so you can
pull the other blue stick to the side, and
carefully weave it over the tip of the yellow
stick, locking it back into place under the
green. The Four Square is done, and despite
it’s humble look, it’ll still blow to
pieces just like all the others.
Now a quick and cool variation of the Four
Square is the Flying Fish. Simply slide two
of the edges on the square toward each other,
then turn it 90º and do the same thing with
the other two edges. To finish up, gently
push two opposite corners together, and it’ll
compress the square into a flat diamond shape.
Now it has the look of an exotic fish, and
should make a nice addition to your collection.
The hardest stick bomb to make is a six pointed
throwing star, and you’ll need 6 sticks,
if you’re up for the challenge. Lay the
blue stick down first, then place the red
and yellow sticks in a “V” pattern overlapping
it in the middle by about an inch, and with
the yellow stick on top. Now take the orange
stick and push one end under the blue tip,
then angle it toward the center. Do the same
thing on the other side with the green stick,
and place the tip so it’s overlapping the
orange one at the top. Now grab the purple
stick and hold everything in place with one
hand, while pushing the purple stick under
the tip of the red one. Bend it over the green
and orange tips, then lock it together underneath
the yellow stick. It probably won’t look
very pretty at first, but if you carefully
tweak the sticks, so the tips line up, you’ll
end up with a really cool looking, 6 pointed
throwing star like this. These are the hardest
ones to make, so if you’re able to build
these, you’ll be a master, on the stick
bomb battlefield.
Well now you know how to use a handful of
popsicle sticks to create an arsenal of exploding
throwing stars. Whether it’s just for fun,
or for defending your empire in popsicle stick
warfare.
By the way, I used 6 sticks to build a bonus
bomb, but I won’t show you how to make it.
Instead, let’s see if you can figure out
how to do it on your own.
And if you find that regular popsicle sticks
are too hard to work with, try using jumbo
craft sticks, or tongue depressors instead.
They’re actually a lot easier to use, and
might be more intimidating to your enemies,
as well.
Well that’s it for now. If you like this
project perhaps you’ll like some of my others.
Check them out at www.thekingofrandom.com